I think the animation and the flavor of
the movie is so original and fresh
what we wanted to do was create an
incredibly fun and engaging version of
the Ninja Turtles we had this idea that
they had to feel like real teenagers
Turtle Boy actually I would say teams
they need to look like teenagers they
need to sound like teenagers who's like
what if it's animated by teenagers it's
the Doodles that you do and the size of
your notebook were taken extrapolated
and made into the look of a whole movie
weird shapes and praising perspective
you would reach this point where you're
like a little bit more rescue and
misshapen great it's perfect
he kept using this term teenage energy
over and over again
let's go let's go
bigger swings visually these animated
movies are taking the more excited
people seem to be by them